ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome
to the Huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an Ask Me
Anything episode or AMA.
This is part of our
premium subscriber channel.
Our premium subscriber
channel was started in order
to provide support for
the standard Huberman Lab
podcast, which comes
out every Monday
and is available at
0 cost to everybody
on all standard feeds, YouTube,
Apple, Spotify and elsewhere.
We also started the
premium channel as a way
to generate support for
exciting research being
done at Stanford and elsewhere.
Research on human
beings that leads
to important
discoveries that assist
mental health, physical
health, and performance.
I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar
of the Huberman
Lab Premium channel
generates for research studies,
the Tiny foundation has
agreed to match that amount.
So now we are able to double
the total amount of funding
given to studies of mental
health, physical health,
and human performance.
If you'd like to subscribe
to the Huberman Lab podcast
Premium channel, please go
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
It is $10 a month to subscribe,
or you can pay $100 all at once
to get an entire 12-month
subscription for a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscription model
that is a one-time payment.
And again, you can
find that option
at hubermanlab.com/premium.
For those of you that
are already subscribers
to the premium channel, please
go to hubermanlab.com/premium,
and download the premium
subscription feed.
And for those of you that
are not Huberman Lab podcast
premium subscribers,
you can still
hear the first 20 minutes
of today's episode,
and determine whether or not
becoming a premium subscriber
is for you.
And now without further ado,
I will answer your questions.
And as always, I
will strive to be
as thorough as possible,
as clear as possible,
and as concise as possible.
Our first question is about
abstaining from thoughts.
And in answering
this question, we're
going to skirt right
up against a topic
that I've covered before
on the podcast which
is obsessive compulsive
disorder, which
is a very serious disorder.
I mean, it can have
a range of severity,
but people with true
OCD suffer a lot
from obsessions, these
are intrusive thoughts,
and compulsions, which are the
behaviors typically associated
with those thoughts.
I think it's really
important that we define
OCD really clearly so
that we can make sure
that we're talking
about intrusive thoughts
and the desire to abstain
from thoughts versus OCD
and where there might
be some overlap there.
The functional definition
of OCD that really pertains
to the disorder, obsessive
compulsive disorder,
OCD as opposed to we
call people neurotic,
or we say you have
OCD, or I'm so
OCD about this,
or OCD about that,
that's become a common
use of the acronym OCD.
But true OCD is a
situation in which
engaging in a particular
compulsive behavior
does not serve to reduce the
intensity or the frequency
of the obsessions.
In fact, it makes it worse.
So the typical thing
that we hear these days
is oh, you're so OCD, or
he's so OCD, or she's so OCD,
or I'm so OCD.
Now if someone is OCD in
that sense, OK, so not
the clinical disorder
but OCD in the sense
that they're really clean,
they're really fastidious,
they need everything perfect.
However, that person can achieve
some level of calm and comfort
that's fairly long
lasting if everything's
clean and perfect,
well, then that's not
obsessive compulsive disorder.
This is really
important to understand
as we venture into
answering the question
about intrusive
thoughts and the desire
to abstain from
certain thoughts.
A person with true OCD will
keep cleaning and cleaning,
or washing their hands,
or arranging things
at perfect right angles,
but the more they
do it, the more their
anxiety goes up.
A person who has more typical,
gosh, we don't really even
have a language for this
nowadays unfortunately,
but the sort of person that's
extremely particular, they need
things a certain way, and
they're very driven to resolve
things and do things to make
sure that things are done
in a certain way, or
handled in a certain way,
well, if that person
can experience relief
from engaging in let's say,
exercise, or from cleaning,
you'd say you're so
OCD about exercise.
Well, but if exercising for
an hour or even two hours
in the morning make somebody
really calm the rest of the day
and they don't need
to exercise well,
then they're not
necessarily true OCD.
They don't necessarily have a
disorder related to exercise.
However, if they're exercising
for two hours in the morning
and then they find
they can't concentrate
on other things and their desire
to exercise just increases
and increases and becomes
intrusive for them disrupting
their quality of life
throughout the day,
well, then that's falling
under the umbrella of what
we would call a true disorder.
So we want to highlight
that because the question is
about a desire to
abstain from thoughts,
and the question is,
in your discussion
with Dr. Anna Lembke--
and I should just
mention Dr. Anna Lembke is the
director of our Dual Diagnosis
Addiction Clinic at Stanford
University School of Medicine.
She's the author of this
incredible book Dopamine Nation
that I think
everybody should read.
I do believe everyone
should read that book.
So important for the
addict and nonaddict
alike because it deals with
basically the state of our life
nowadays.
We're living in this
dopamine rich world
where we can quickly become
dopamine depleted, which
is terrible, leads to
depression in addition to things
like addiction in
some folks, et cetera.
Anna was a guest on the podcast.
You can find her episode
at hubermanlab.com.
Just put Anna.
I think she's the
only guest we've
had thus far whose name is Anna,
so it'll just pop up there.
The entire website
is searchable.
But if you want to
listen to that episode
or watch that episode, you
can access it hubermanlab.com.
The question is
in your discussion
with Dr. Anna Lembke you
were talking about abstaining
from people's drug
of choice for 30 days
to reset the dopamine
reward pathway.
And indeed that is the
prescriptive that Dr. Anna
Lembke gives for
most all addictions
and for people that are
suffering from milder even
severe depression
related to dopamine
seeking behaviors, social
media, video games, sex, food,
et cetera.
However, of course, in
the instance of food
or in some other addictions,
you can't abstain for 30 days.
That would be terrible to
abstain for food for 30 days.
I'm sure people have done it,
but it is not healthy to do.
Certain things like
alcohol and drugs people
can abstain for
30 days in efforts
to never go back to them again.
There are cases of
severe alcohol or opiate
dependence where people can't go
cold turkey or they risk dying,
so there they need to really
work with a physician.
But the 30-day reset
of the dopamine system
is something that's
very real and that
pertains to most people.
That is it's going to be
very effective for most
people struggling with
either behavioral,
or what are sometimes
called process addictions,
or other types of addictions
including substance abuse
issues.
The question continues.
You said you were
going to ask Ana
how to abstain if
your drug of choice
is a thought or
narrative as opposed
to a substance or a behavior.
The question continues,
as far as I can tell,
your discussion
with Ana moved on
before you asked
her the question.
Would you be able to
discuss strategies
for abstaining from addictive
thoughts and narratives?
OK.
So let's talk about
intrusive thoughts,
and let's start off by asking
ourselves, what is a thought?
In the realm of
neurobiology, we have
sensations which are the
processes by which our neurons,
nerve cells convert light,
photons, sound waves, touch,
mechanical pressure, et
cetera into electrical signals
and chemical signals that
head into our nervous system,
including our brain.
And then our brain, at least
we think, make sense of them,
and help us navigate
the world that we're in.
So the sensation part
is a pure transformation
of mechanical information,
or in some cases,
chemical information like smell.
Literally, volatile chemicals
floating around in the world
are brought in through
your nose and your neurons
and your olfactory
bulb convert those
into electrical and
chemical signals
that your brain can understand.
Perceptions are your idea
of what those signals out
in the world are.
Either because you're
paying attention
to them, or for some
other reason you decide
that stop sign in
front of you is red,
and that the sign
behind it is white,
and that the sky is blue or
cloudy, those are perceptions.
So we have sensations
and perceptions.
Then we have emotions
which are these things that
include the mind and
body that are related
to neuromodulators like
dopamine, serotonin, et cetera,
although, those chemicals
do other things as well.
And then, of course, we
have behaviors, actions.
Everything from me moving
my pen on a piece of paper
to walking, running, et cetera.
Thoughts are a fifth
category of neural
functioning that we
really need to define,
but that doesn't have
as strict a definition
as sensations, perceptions,
or feeling, or action.
But thoughts are real.
We all know this.
Thoughts are real, and one way
that we can define thoughts
is that thoughts are
perceptions that include data
from the past, present,
or future, or combinations
of past and present, or present
and future, or future and past.
I'm not trying to give an overly
complicated definition here,
but if we are going to
answer a question about how
to abstain from
thoughts in a really
direct and actionable
way, we really
need to address
what our thoughts.
So thoughts are perceptions
that are generated internally.
We don't need any
external sensation
in order to have a thought.
We can close our eyes.
We could be in sensory
isolation for that matter.
We could even be
floating with no gravity,
and we can have a thought.
Thoughts tend to run pretty much
automatically in the background
all the time.
Some people refer
to this as chatter
in the back of our minds
in a very unstructured way.
And then if we
force our thoughts
to be structured because
we decide they need to be,
or if something
in our environment
captures our perception,
then our thoughts
tend to be structured.
Let me give you an example.
If I'm just walking
around, if there
were a way in which
we could broadcast
my thoughts onto a screen,
I hope we wouldn't do that.
But those thoughts
would be a mixture
of semi-complete
sentences and gibberish.
However if somebody
stops me, and says, hi.
Good to see you.
What are you doing today?
And I start answering,
well, then my thoughts
are suddenly being driven
by an external stimulus,
their question, and some
internal ideas, memory
of who I am and what
I'm doing that day so
past and present, and so on.
And so thoughts
become structured.
So when we have a question about
how to abstain from thoughts,
we need to be
additionally specific
and really pinpoint that
what we're trying to do
is to abstain from thoughts we
don't want presumably, either
because they are too
repetitive and distracting,
or because what's contained in
those thoughts is disturbing.
This is important because
it gives us two answers
to the questions that
are highly divergent.
One answer to the
question of how
to abstain from intrusive
thoughts, thoughts that
were addicted to, is if
those thoughts are merely
on loop all the time
and we can't stop them,
but the thoughts themselves
aren't particularly disturbing.
So think about a song you
can't get out of your head,
or you keep
recounting some event,
but the event itself
isn't very disturbing.
It's just intrusive
because it's there.
Well, in that case,
the data really
point to trying to
anchor your thoughts
to some external stimulus.
So getting into action,
getting into activities
that really draw your attention
away from that thought.
Now you may still hear it
scrolling in the background,
so you might be sitting in
class still hearing that loop
of thoughts in the background.
That's something that
over time ought to wane,
it ought to disappear
if we try and bring
more and more attention
to whatever it
is that's in our
environment, whatever
it is that we happen to be
learning or doing physically,
et cetera.
Things like mindful meditation.
Doing a 10 or even
just 5 minute a day
practice of sitting
with eyes closed,
or lying down with eyes
closed and really focusing
on one's breath, focusing
one's attention on sometimes
called the third eye
center, but in science we'd
say just the region right
behind the forehead,
you're directing
your attention there,
has been shown to increase
focus for singular topics
and can improve memory and do a
bunch of other things as well.
Those are data from Dr. Wendy
Suzuki's lab at New York
University.
She was a guest on
the podcast as well.
My laboratory has run studies
on mindful meditation as well.
So what you're
really trying to do
is learn how to focus
better on one thing,
and by focusing
on that one thing,
you focus off these
repetitive thoughts.
Now, I have a feeling that
this question was asked
and that many people
upvoted this question
because the issue isn't
just thoughts that
are intrusive because
they're there and on repeat,
but because the thoughts
themselves are actually
troubling.
This could be recounting a
trauma, someone harmed you,
you observed something that was
disturbing, you felt wronged,
you felt someone
else was wronged,
you can't seem to get your
mind off of something,
and your emotions
tend to follow,
and so it's uncomfortable.
I have a feeling this is
the root of the question.
In that case, the approach
is very different.
What we know from essentially
all of the quality
scientific and
clinical studies is
that those sorts of
intrusive thoughts
are very much like a trauma.
Now we have to be clear in
defining what trauma is.
I'll use the definition
that Dr. Paul
Conti, another incredible
guest that was on our podcast.
A Stanford-Harvard
trained psychiatrist.
I think one of the
world's foremost leaders
on the issue of trauma and
psychiatry and psychology
generally.
He defines trauma as an event
or something that fundamentally
changes the way that your
nervous system works such
that you function less
adaptively going forward
from that event.
So not every bad occurrence
in your life is a trauma.
That's good news.
The bad news is many
people have traumas,
and traumas change the way
that our nervous system
works so that we don't
function as well as we could.
So in that sense, intrusive
thoughts that are disturbing
are in many ways traumas and
are reinforcing that trauma.
Now, we know that almost
counterintuitively
in order to deal
with trauma, you
have to get very
close to that trauma.
You don't have to
reexpose, and I
would hope you would
not reexpose yourself
to the very same trauma.
But we know that one of the
best ways to deal with traumas
is to get very clear about the
narrative around those traumas.
Now this can be done
with a therapist ideally,
but not everyone has access to
therapy or can afford therapy.
There's a range of quality of
therapists for that matter,
so we're always referring
to the desire for people
to do great therapy
with really great,
meaning excellently
trained people.
But it turns out that if you
want to extinguish an intrusive
thought, one of the
best ways to do that
is to journal about that
particular thought extensively.
So rather than the earlier
strategy for intrusive thoughts
where they're just on
loop, and intrusive
because they're on
loop and present,
but their content
isn't disturbing,
when that thought is
disturbing and intrusive,
we know that it's very
useful to script out
as much detail about
that particular thought
and the things around
it as possible.
Now obviously, you want
to do this in a way that
is fairly structured.
So you ideally would
use complete sentences.
So the reason for doing
that is that thoughts,
as I mentioned earlier,
can often be fragmentary.
So they pop up in
our mind almost
we seemingly spontaneously.
They're inhibiting
our ability to focus,
or be present at work, or
family, or other things,
or sleep.
Writing things down
in a lot of detail
does seem to have this
quality of both reducing
the emotional load of whatever
it is that thought is about,
as well as diminishing the
frequency of those intrusive
thoughts over time.
So this is far and away
different than the strategy
I mentioned for the other
types of intrusive thoughts.
And really it's far
and away different
from the 30-day
abstinence approach
that Dr. Anna Lembke was
talking about for substance
or behavioral addictions.
Now, of course, this process
of abstaining from thoughts
or removing the addictive
nature of certain thoughts
can definitely take some time.
So a good example there
would be superstitions.
I'll come clean
here, and I've talked
about this before
on a few podcasts
that when I was in
college, I developed
a knock on wood superstition.
Any time I'd say something that
I didn't want to happen or did
want to happen, I'd say, knock
on wood, and I'd knock on wood.
And then I started suppressing
the behavior mostly
because it was a
little embarrassing.
And then I started just
telling myself in my head,
knock on wood, knock
on wood, knock on wood.
And it was clearly a little
bit of an OCD type thing,
but again, OCD in
air quotes here.
I think it qualified
as OCD in the sense
that the more I did it,
the more I wanted to do it.
So I needed to go cold
turkey on the thinking,
but how can you go cold
turkey on a thought?
You couldn't.
What I was told to do and
what worked very well for me
was to just write down
the worst possible outcome
that I was concerned about.
So to really get close to the
nature or the underlying basis
of that intrusive thought.
And I raise this
because a lot of times
the intrusive thought
is not, OK, I'm
thinking about a
car accident, or I'm
thinking about a breakup, or
I'm thinking about an exam
that I have.
That can be intrusive,
but a lot of times
it's some kind of
nebulous, abstract,
set of words, or ideas,
or images around something
that happened that we saw
or heard or experienced.
And by putting a lot
of clear structure
to what the thought is exactly
and to putting some thought
and structure onto paper
about what that pattern of not
healthy thinking
relates to, people often
achieve tremendous relief in
a fairly short amount of time.
Sometimes just in one
session of writing it down,
sometimes they need to write
it down multiple times.
What you're essentially trying
to do with a intrusive thought
or a trauma of
any kind is you're
trying to turn a disturbing
story, that is a story that
evokes a lot of
emotion and captures,
it hijacks your nervous system,
into what is essentially
a known but repetitive
and old, boring story
where the emotional
load has been depleted.
And there are, of course, I
have to highlight the fact
that getting sufficient rapid
eye movement sleep we also know
is very important for
removing the emotional load
of traumatic experiences
and intrusive thoughts.
So you really want to strive to
get the best possible sleep you
can.
That includes sufficient
rapid eye movement sleep.
And we have multiple
zero-cost resources
for that at hubermanlab.com.
We have the episode
on mastery or sleep.
We have the episode on
perfecting your sleep.
We have the toolkit for sleep.
All of which are time
stamped and all of which
can be accessed to completely
zero cost to try and get
your sleep as good as
possible, including lots
of rapid eye movement sleep.
So in order to remove intrusive
and addictive thoughts,
ask yourself, is this
OCD of the classic sense?
If it is, you should
see a psychiatrist.
They won't necessarily
prescribe medication,
but there are tools
for true OCD that are
very effective in many cases.
And we did the episode
on OCD which I invite
you to listen to as well.
You want to ask yourself,
are the thoughts
disturbing or merely
intrusive and repetitive?
If they're merely intrusive
and repetitive, well,
then learning to focus your
attention on other things
and getting better at
focusing on single things
through an exercise
like mindfulness,
meditation can really help.
And indeed perhaps the best
use of mindfulness meditation
is to improve your
level of focus.
It does have other
benefits as well,
but that's going to be the major
one that one will experience
even with these very short 5
or 10-minute day meditations.
Great data on that from
the scientific literature.
And then if those intrusive
thoughts are not only intrusive
but they're also
disturbing, in that case,
you really want to put as
much structure and thought,
believe it or not, into
what those thoughts are
really about.
Write them out on paper
in complete sentences
and maybe do that multiple
times until the underlying
emotions related
to those thoughts
really start to diminish.
And by doing that,
you're essentially
doing your own form
of trauma therapy,
for lack of a better
way to put it.
And again, the data
really point to the fact
that getting close to
the specific details
around those
intrusive thoughts is
going to be the best
way to extinguish them.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning
of this Ask Me Anything episode.
To hear the full episode and to
hear future episodes of these
Ask Me Anything sessions, plus
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
Lab podcast standard channel
and premium tools not
released anywhere else,
please go to
hubermanlabs.com/premium
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman Lab
podcast Premium channel
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's
to raise support
for the standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel which,
of course, will still be
continued to be released
every Monday in full length.
We are not going to
change the format
or anything about the
standard Huberman Lab podcast.
And to fund research, in
particular research done
on human beings.
So not animal models
but on human beings,
which I think we all
agree is the species
that we are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically fund
research that is aimed
toward developing
further protocols for mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
And those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels.
Not just the premium channel
but through all channels,
Huberman Lab podcast and
other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions in depth, and
allow you the opportunity
to support the research that
provides those kinds of answers
in the first place.
Now an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel
is that the Tiny
Foundation has generously
offered to do a
dollar-for-dollar match
on all funds raised for research
through the premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science-related tools for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for the
Huberman Lab Premium channel,
again there's a cost
of $10 per month,
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMAs,
you can ask questions and get
answers to your questions,
and you'll, of course, get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content such as transcripts
of the AMAs and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast
episodes not found elsewhere.
And again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]